I have a voicemail number which you were invited
to call anytime of day whenever you get the
hankering.
Just give me a call.
Two one nine two.
David P. Here is a voicemail.
I got about 20 grand I've been waiting for.
Take a listen to this.
I remember a few days ago it was last.
You mentioned that the creator of Parler,
the conservative Twitter Khlong, said that
if they would offer a bounty of it.
Twenty thousand dollars.
Yes, progressive with over 50000 followers.
Indeed, it was vice versa.
But either way, you said you tried to take
him up on that and he still hasn't paid you
back.
And I'm wondering, has he ever.
His offer.
No.
So basically yet parler.
You know, Republicans said our free speech
rights are being taken away on Twitter.
So some guy created an app called Parler and
he said multiple times right around the July
4th long weekend holiday that if any progressive
with over 50000 Twitter followers signs up,
they'll pay them a twenty thousand dollar
bounty.
So I have one hundred and thirty thousand
Twitter followers.
I signed up.
I tweeted to the guy.
I said, I'm I'm ready for my 20 grand.
Didn't say anything.
Next day I tweeted again, I did what you said.
I signed up.
I'm ready for my 20 grand.
Still got nothing.
And ultimately, I just deleted the parlor
account.
So in addition to being liars about the circumstances
of censorship on social media, also liars
in terms of they said we'll pay 20 grand if,
you know, I met the requirements and they
did not pay me.
You may not be surprised by that.
We are going to talk on the we've not talked
a lot on the bonus show about the return of
sports in the Corona virus era.
There's actually some really interesting things
going on which I want to discuss.
We're also going to talk about a black woman
facing prison for a voting mistake.
And prosecutors just doubled the charges against
her.
And Donald Trump has ordered undocumented
immigrants excluded from a very important
census count.
Remember, it's 2020.
The census is going on in the midst of everything
else that's happening.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Remember, you can get instant.
I'm talking instant, instantaneous speed of
light access to the daily bonus show by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com or two options,
become a patron at Patrie on dot com slash
David Pakman show.
We'll see you on the bonus show.
Or if not, tragically, we won't see you until
tomorrow.